what's this thing cool ready for this
that wasn't cool do it in slow-mo and
it's cool do that in slow-mo today we
are on a ways of Las Vegas and what is
Vegas known for the face so we're gonna
go to three drastically different
buffets as three drastically different
price points to find out which one was
worth it at its price so last time you
went to Vegas you're in different
company Keith Stephen best buddies for
life I have matured a lot now I'm not
gonna just be screaming out Vegas baby
it'll be my first time ever
what should I scream that Vegas baby
usually we could learn of Vegas that are
confiscated when they're toxic they just
want to eat a lot of food we're gonna
find out how good the food is uh
Nantucket I mean if there's a ring spa
thing maybe will heart take the little
we have to have full experience we got
to do our job see okay so Vegas baby you
said her Vegas baby
I know you like to have an occasional
training I like to have a good time Adam
is a good time and that's Vegas baby
it's not about the destination
yada yada
my name is Timothy Radigan and I'm the
executive chef for the feast buffet here
at Red Rock we do breakfast lunch and
dinner today we have breakfast out we do
omelets we do scrambled eggs we carve
bone-in ham our desert station is open
we have breakfast pastries I'm a we have
a hundred and fifty-four items available
for breakfast almost everything here is
made from scratch which you rarely find
out above a feast buffet always been
behind supporting locals we try and keep
things changing just so there's variety
for people that come a few times a week
how do you keep all the food fresh with
the sheer numbers that we do is
fantastic because the food goes how much
is the breakfast buffet here breakfast
is $6.99 for club members and it's $8.99
without the car what that is crazy
you ready yeah let's do it go in Andrew
I'm gone gonna play usually we share a
dick here but now we're at a book fan
yeah buffets is not about sharing
because I was in charge of making my
plate kind of threw balance out the
window got an eggs benny jelly doughnut
yellow it's about variety of experience
i want as many different textures
happening on my plate as possible not
only did you getting eggs benedict but
you also got an omelette that's half the
size of your plate what's with that I
like eggs you got to stay loose what
just came out yeah what's looking good
my god the ham I forgot about that I
forgot about the carbs ham oh you got
the hash brown eye I'm gonna be having
some of your hash break it off my ash
brown can we cheers plates yeah we can
cheers plates
all right regular Topanga you can't even
see your red velvet pancakes in they're
covered by a wok no no no it's topped
with a wok I'm gonna go for my wrench
there since that's the closest thing I
have to a red velvet pancake here we go
whoa it's so fluffy
that was delicious that's probably the
best thing that they have here start
with a little eggy action oh yeah eggs
with you these are actually very good
scrambled eggs Nance produce scrambled
eggs are usually among the worst foods
but these are great this is not powder a
no crack an egg is back there I saw a
big old bowl of eggs look at the how
thick that ham steak is you just like
gave me a nice carve you up a hunk my
college roommate really love ham steaks
seeing that ham makes me think of him
it's good ham yes an omelet I'm good I'm
enjoy watching you
fluffy boom we feast it no I like about
the face reminds me of weird a family
memories I don't go to buffet alone
usually I have been actually Adam guys
I'm like drunk on buffets and it's only
the first buffet I paced myself that's
your problem you went in too hard they
were really moving food there nothing
was really sitting around unless it's
meant to sit around like jello you know
what time it is but a fact NASA says
that the brightest spot on earth that
you can see from space is the Las Vegas
Strip Wow
how many of those lights are buffets ooh
a helicopter oh we're actually now on
the stress what the tourists are where
the magic happens
so where we going to next well first
time in the bathrooms I'm gonna go to
get some business and unpack my body Hey
here the next place we're going is the
wicked spin spoon is my favorite utensil
[Music]
hey I'm Rory chef de cuisine and wicked
spoon we're here at the restaurant now
it's dinnertime wicked spoon what does
that mean so it's taking a kind of a
different angle is something outside the
box like we have the frog legs and bone
marrow certain things that you won't see
on like the normal buffet just being
wicked with it I noticed like the size
of the plate is different than the
normal that they like that's the spoon
part so everything's cooked to order
basically so we've set these up and the
little individual dishes is already
plated for it which makes it cleaner
it helps you not overheat and us to
alleviate the waste as well I mean
you're not gonna be able to stop him
from overeating never stop eating let's
not forget who almost wrecked themselves
at brunch today what's the thing you're
most excited to try cuz we got a lot to
cover here first it was a pork belly but
for me it's the bourbon glaze baby
carrots never been excited that you
cared in my life what about you raagh
leg grits or crawfish bone marrow
anything goes here in the wicked spoon
alright so first things first I'm the
realest we were recommended to get would
keep the margarita wicked means good in
this context for those who are not up
with the times like this kid right here
for ninety ninety such a baby
when were you born 1990 this is too easy
to drink watch right now Stephen you see
the duck heads they're not bringing
Chuck meat in this place they're
bringing ducks mmm got pork belly Oh
rich and all fatty and delicious oh my
god no that poor Billy was a better than
what he - in your mouth you want to
waiver that actually is way better than
the pork belly's a touchdown I've
actually never had a frog legs before
what's a high five called if you use
your foot
frog foot five hmm technically we just
knocked the thighs together
I've had a lot of problems in my life
have you it's a very classic tiny dish
but I'd never had Buffalo probably
that's a good buffalo sauce it's
actually got a nice heat to it
Wow you're just weird of that bone come
out of your mouth you were like storing
it back there like a squirrel getting
ready for winter what have you probably
were to eat this bone marrow yeah if you
want to like suck on the bone I know
your bones that bear is really good yep
I got a fortune cookie your health is
important eat your vegetables
baby carrots bourbon-glazed yeah they
use a makers mark it is not cheap
whiskey and it's not a whiskey that you
would expect someone to cook with it
wasn't overcooked till you got that
crunch there right not only is that a
nice glaze the carrot flavor is not
missing what oh that's carrot cake I've
had a carrot cake every birthday of my
life
very good carrot cake Oh Oh for the
amount and range of stuff you get here
the crab there's duck the pork belly the
prime rib no this is every episode but
for real this is the place I'm gonna
bring my girlfriend yeah this is
brilliant
hard to beat this that was the perfect
buffet really the food was super unique
the chef was awesome there were things
that I'd never had before and I didn't
expect to try new food at a buffet I
gotta say I was loud you know the : Oh
face not like the : of your body because
ain't calling D face but neither is good
buffet that there was a study done so
one group at four dog buffet daily group
had a dog buffet and the people who paid
$8 actually said that the pizzas taste
better and the people who paid $4 even
though it was the exact same
so you're saying lying works if Vegas
has taught me anything it's that blowing
money can be pleasurable in itself hey
if a buffet tastes better because I'm
splurging a little more money on it
that's just a better buffet sorry we
woke up this morning at 8:30 to go to
one of the most classic buffets
in Las Vegas going to the Sterling
brunch which is only on Sundays it's a
pretty special thing I'm ready
hi I'm Elizabeth Brayden Watkins I'm
this is an executive chef of Bally's
Paris at Planet Hollywood
we're here at sterling brunch at Bally's
this brunch is actually a Vegas
tradition it's over 30 years old so has
this always been the premier Vegas
brunch it has I think people have an
expectation of what sterling brunch is
supposed to be that's why you have the
champagne and the caviar and lobster so
right here is our fresh seafood station
we have the Blue Point oysters and crab
claws there is a sterling brunch
specialty omelette that's Webster is
famous for lobster bores and cognac this
is our carving station we have the bacon
prime rib and lamb that's a staple we
have a variety of pastries that are made
by our in-house pastry chef I personally
always love chocolate-covered
strawberries how often is this brunch
open it's open every Sunday being that
it's one day a week it makes it very
easier for us to make sure that we're
bringing the quality in as fresh as
possible how much is the brunch it's $95
wow that's the all you can have
champagne included so it's definitely
worth it now feels like we're in Vegas
even the regular buffet foods elevated
because everything here looks so good
that we didn't make our own place we
just got the best stuff and we're gonna
share it all in true worth it warm oh
hello good morning welcome to the
Sterling brunch champagne wishes and
caviar dreams I'm Duff I've been here
for 18 years started in 1998 you got any
good brunch stories favorite person
you've ever waited on Rodney Dangerfield
that's how he was in real life he would
just come in as like hey how's it going
thanks a lot for your service you want
to do some of this
I love camping in the sound of popping
champagne whoo here comes the buffet
look at this popover it kind of looks
like an ice cream cone made of puff
pastry Oh
[Music]
this is amazing I mean this doesn't need
butter until pill feeding let's go to
this egg lobster cognac horse on omelet
[Music]
it's one of the stinkier cheese's but
with the butteriness of the lobster yeah
really nice own a caviar and this omelet
and make it even crazier obviously not
really
it's actually really good like a
combination of all right whoo all the
sudden there's like this sea breeze
washing over the cheese it's like a
puzzle it is a puzzle for your mouth to
solve can I ask you another question was
mr. Dangerfield favorite thing to eat he
was right up those lobster tails well I
mean you got to do the lobster tails
[Music]
is that your favorite thing so far it
really is probably cooked and so so good
dessert time so she recommended I bury
can I get the white chocolate one white
chocolate is for children
[Music]
[Music]
strawberries nice and tart chocolate
dark and sweet the perfect strawberry
yesterday you said you're gonna bring
your girlfriend to wicked spoon yeah
this is where I'm bringing my girlfriend
come on we're in the desert in Nevada
and I'm eating lobster from the bottom
of the ocean and there's no way it's
from yesterday's brunch you did they
only have it once a week
sterling brunch done done guys I'm
intoxicated by the sheer volume of food
that we have consumed on this trip I'm
more food drunk than any other kind of
drunk exactly what I just said I said it
better
so Andrew Adam what do you guys think
what was the best buffet at its given
price point Red Rock was a ridiculous
value I don't know that I've ever eaten
more food for less cost
that being said that sterling brunch was
ridiculous stuff in his tuxedo and his
eyepatch with his stories of Rodney
Dangerfield like that's worth the price
alone my worth it winner
sterling brunch I guess I'm a high
roller now there's just oh my my straw
yo pull the go room pin this puppy we
didn't want to play Red Rock it was
under $10 and it was all of the plastics
that you wanted done well my worth of
Wednesday goes to the wicked spoon
everything was like a good dish plus
something special I would have liked
vegetables growing up as a kid if I eat
eight his care yeah all kids should be
doing whiskey carrots had him whoa
you know I'd like to do an episode on
little birds pheasant whale to eat or as
pets tea
you
oh yes